hey guys i'm ruby rose and i'm doing the
wired auto complete interview i've just
found out what that actually is
uh i should read my emails more
thoroughly
the internet is a scary place and i
would never google myself and now i have
to know what people google about me do
not meta that is
[Music]
what is ruby rose's real name uh ruby
rose
langenheim langenheim is my last name
ruby's my first name rose is my middle
name rippy rose seemed a bit more catchy
than ruby langenheim
just a little like for now maybe i'll
change it later what
i thought it said what seasoning and i
was like oh let me tell you my recipes
what season of orange is the new black
is ruby rose i'm gonna say
in i was glad i didn't say fired or
something
not that i was fired but i'm in season
three i started an episode
i don't know that'll be yeah not sure
and then
season four i come back for an episode
as well oh that show was so good
that was one of the best experiences of
my life and
is really why i'm here today um not
literally on the planet but as in why
i'm able to do things like this and act
and do my job and
that job was the entry point so jen
houston and genji cohen i always shout
them out
they believed in me what does ruby rose
eat
because i'm vegan i do get this a lot
it's like what do you eat
salad i eat everything that anyone else
eats
but without any animal products without
any dairy without anything that
has come from an animal and i eat a lot
and i enjoy it
in fact right now i'm still wondering if
if my
bottom half is on camera or if i can
undo my top button of my jeans
but i can't quite work it out so i'm
just going to keep it done up but you
know
i eat and i enjoy it what is ruby rose
what is rippy rose famous for i have no
idea
i mean i'm guessing well i started as a
vj
at mtv and then i became a dj then i
hosted the winter olympics which is a
questionable choice i had no sport
knowledge and so i would just make
things up
torah bright won a gold medal and i was
like she just did a double
kangaroo backflip koala land and i did
curling with michael buble that could be
why i'm famous
i was in a terrible video clip when i
was young for a band that doesn't exist
i could be famous for that i'm guessing
it's probably oranges in your black
mostly and acting and doing really weird
interviews that people wish weren't
online anymore
that person is me oh well that's sad
isn't it
just like how the wording was ripped off
as was my neck tattoo
it did say and breathe me uh and now
says
because this is a few bits still there
it's my favorite singer song and then i
became really close was there we became
really good friends
and it took me like a year to notice
that it said that and that was weird
but that's not why i got it removed then
it was fine but uh yeah it's gone
oh there's more i thought i did so well
i thought i got so lucky can't no this
is great guys i'm having such a good
time is it hiding here
oh i don't like this one okay ruby rose
did ruby rose what did i do or did i not
did ruby rose do her own stunts i don't
know what film or show that's about but
yes
to all of them i always do my own stunts
that's one of the most fun parts about
doing action films
and anything involving physical training
and all that kind of stuff is
it would be weird to just let somebody
else do it all i mean i have a stunt
double
obviously and they come in and do
certain things as well but mostly i do
my own but it would be weird if you just
walked on set
after someone did all this stuff and
you're just talking you're like hey
how was that like you have to be feeling
it and in the motion of it and know how
tired you would be and
i love doing it absolutely love it ruby
rose dog
i'm not a dog i want to come back as a
dog
i think dogs are my favorite thing in
the world if they're a thing creature
animal i have three
i have charlie chance and rue chance is
one that can't walk
rue is the one with the human eyes it's
always staring at me and
charlie's on with a broken jaw and
they're all beautiful and they're all
rescues and
rose dog is my favorite we can just we
can have this here now with that that's
beautiful
ah dogs ruby rose gender pronouns
she her hand over rose play guitar yes
you can
i'm not as good as i used to be but i
love playing guitar and it's one thing
that i've picked up more
during all this sort of off time and
quarantine can ruby rose
run fast uh i don't know if i can run
fast if
anyone here is planning on chasing me
we'll find out ruby rose
crocs yeah you know i i almost saw them
today and then i was like
you're actually in public for the first
time in a while and
i'm always wearing crocs even in public
but today i was like i'll put sneakers
with laces on today i'll be fancy
i designed two pairs of crocs and
they're the most comfortable shoe in the
world
i love them not an ad not being paid by
them anymore but do love them
so good i should have worn crocs
why ruby rose i ask myself that all the
time
why would be right why are you doing
this interview why are you answering
these questions
ruby rose removed tattoos i didn't
remember very many i just removed one on
my neck
another one here and i'm sort of doing
my knuckles and
my hand and that's only because i don't
really mind doing extra time and makeup
in the makeup chair for tattoo coverage
for every film ever
but the hands you wash your hands every
day and now oh my goodness can you
imagine you wash them even
even more and for longer so the makeup
on your hands doesn't last when i do
films and it ends up all icky and gross
and then by lunch i'm like am i eating
food or is this like
foundation that's falling off cracking
off of my knuckles
so yeah and same with the the neck it
just it's easier to keep that kind of
clean
why did ruby
rose wait why did roopy rose gets oh i
was like
these are real there's nothing there
i've had a few surgeries
but not any fun ones i got surgery
because i
broke my neck essentially herniated two
discs into my spine almost got paralyzed
but now i'm bionic so my neck is
stronger than any neck out there
why would you wear a short hair i knew
i'd get something like that why rip your
rose long hair
why rerose hair is the question i also
don't know why people care so much about
hair
like i'm not really that interested in
people's hair i mean if you have short
hair long hair
whatever i'm like cool hair not like why
red hair why blonde streaks i shaved my
head
during quarantine because i knew i had
time to grow up back my hair grows
so fast and i did it when i was 16. i
remember how good it felt
and freeing and i recommend it though if
you you know have a choice you feel like
doing it
it's very freeing and hair does grow
back so you guys out there that are
really worried about it
it'll get better why ruby rose vegan
i was vegetarian from a young age i
also was lactose intolerant i also
didn't like eggs
and then eventually i was just eating
fish because the doctor was like you're
a woman you need fish for your brain
and then i ended up with mercury
poisoning which is not
not uncommon it's actually really common
if the planet went vegan
we would be able to eliminate and
actually combat climate change
faster than just like you know driving
less or
whatever you know there's all these
other things we can do turn these lights
off and do
but it's like what we're eating and what
that does to like agriculture and
keeping cows alive and it's a lot of
water it's a lot of
food it's a it's a lot of money and it's
not good for the planet um but i also
don't judge anyone you can eat whatever
you want but i will say
and i said this to all my friends if you
could be vegan or vegetarian
for one day a week or two days a week
even that would have a huge impact on
the planet
just saying and also it tastes great no
excuses
why ruby rose talk so much is that the
next one
why ruby rose they're asking if i've
done animation maybe
i was a wolf called bianca
on a film called sheep and wolves and
then i played
uh well it's not it's not out yet so
it's okay that i forgot what her name is
cool that was great where ruby rose
my friend's little kid parker she's like
five
and she always says like where have ruby
wherever he is
and i'm like i'm here anyway that that's
helping me get over the anxiety of
having to do wear ruby rose okay
i'm thinking of parker where does ruby
rose
live well i live in l.a i've lived in la
for seven years
but this is probably the longest i've
actually spent in la which is really
nice because it is nice to
live in the city that you planned on
living but when you moved to hollywood
from
australia and you're like i'm gonna live
in hollywood and no you're not you're
gonna shoot
films uh where there's tax incentives
and there aren't any here so
uh it's nice to be back where is ruby
rose
from well i just answered that question
but to reiterate i am from australia
melbourne
where is ruby rose in the whap music
video so there's a there's a
rapper called ruby rose but with an eye
um
and i remember when she was starting out
and and i just kept hearing about her
and i'm like who is this chick
and like now she's massive now she's
huge but like she was just coming
through and i went on to her
uh instagram to find out like who is
this person that stole my name and
she's got like this video and it's like
all sexy and she's all like
hot and like saying things that i myself
would never say because it
like just you know sexy rap stuff that
i'm like
you know my my i just wouldn't you know
i i was like oh my god if my mom
starts getting google alerts for like
ruby rose and things that i'm doing a
rap song about like
anyway she's cool she actually
referenced me recently in an interview
and then i could tell by her face
i guess i'm having that moment now but
i'm enjoying it they were like
so you have the same name as uh actress
ruby and she's like
yes yes i do but then she warmed into it
but you can just tell she has had that
she's been asked that question more than
me
and she's clearly over it but she was
very sweet she said nice things about me
where is ruby rose's clothing from oh
iceberg it's also i think written
um it's written on the sleeves so that's
cool it's from iceberg
and i'm wearing these jordans that you
probably can't see
and i'm not yeah this is so cool don't
you want these
they've got cherries on them and all
right cool
where did
ruby rose go to school nice but i'm also
like where's my degree
like in attendance alone i was there
every day
anyway they didn't give me one um and
then i went to
uh university and i went to errol street
primary school great school
i went to university high school less
good school
um more mean people and then i went to
footscray city which was awesome
great school who is
ugh who is ruby rose uh i don't know
me and also a rapper if you change the
last letter on
there on the first name who is
i knew that was going to come up who is
ruby rose dating
wouldn't it be nice if i just told you
wouldn't that just be so cool if i was
like guys i'm dating
no yep um what about this i'll give you
a clue
just kidding who does
ruby rose's haircuts currently myself uh
breezy actually from
all-american she's one of my best
friends she does them but now she's
shooting again so she can't be my baba
because she's a really big time actress
but she was doing all these cool designs
and now it's it's me or my friend
castillo sometimes but my hair is so
short i
just shave it myself who sings for
see who sings for ruby rose in pitch
perfect
if i were gonna have a singing double
you think i would have someone better
right
i wouldn't there's not are you kidding
me it's definitely me singing in pitch
perfect
uh that film was so much fun i really
had a good time
singing like actually myself singing not
having a singing double was one of my
favorite things
not having guitar double also favorite
things that i did on that film
by myself church choir it comes in handy
who is
riviera's mother my mum is cardia
langenheim
she is the most powerful strong
inspiring beautiful kind funny
woman in the world and i love her to
bits and i'm so glad that i got that
question because that one i actually
enjoyed and it didn't give me an anxiety
attack and if she's watching this which
she will cause she watches absolutely
everything i don't want to throw this
one now because it's
like sentimental i'll just keep it here
that's it
thank god uh thank you for watching if
you're still watching
thanks and uh i hope you learned
something
um about
me or questions or google
or what it's like to know what people
google about you something
something came from this wonderful
experience